what do you think about that lebron's
son got caught
on september 19th you want to talk we
want to hear something so here's the
back story on this so
uh lebron was in the bubble right three
months later won the championship and
you know you don't leave the bubble and
he kept his family
out his wife savannah i think came there
for a little bit uh but the kids didn't
and lebron's very close with his
children i mean no no question
but i think i think bronze ticked i mean
i think that's a real problem i mean
was that an accident so what happened
was brony his 16 year old son who's a
basketball phenom
himself you know was caught on instagram
you know posted this little short little
clip of him taking a little puff or
you know smoking weed so that circulated
they took it down but then
the word is when bro lebron got back
from the bubble that he grounded him he
didn't let him go to that that uh
esports event
with uh odell beckham yeah it was
supposed to be this huge and what else
is his worst bronzers
so the word is that lebron grounded him
but man you better nip that in the bud
right now because
you know you're 16 you're representing
that lebron james brand
and you got a lot more to lose than to
gain by uh by smoking weed
do you think lebron's a good father yeah
i think so 100 i think so as well and he
had no he had no reference point he
didn't have a father so i think he's
trying to make up for that but i
i give bron lebron credit for being a
good dad i think lebron is a ridiculous
that
is what i think i think he's a
ridiculous and i think i think he wants
to make up for what he didn't get
and make sure that he his children get
attention i give him a lot of props in
that area when it comes on to
the conversations about uh you know
who's a great father
as a as a face of a league i think
lebron's
got that one taken care of to do his
best to be a great family man
kai i also think it's a little bit
difference of one thing about doing it
if it's like privately or whatever
but then posting it online i mean you're
stupid at that point well yeah extremely
special but you know what
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna come up
later like let me tell you i like his
style that he never
uh publicly embarrassed his son
there's a part of that that i actually
really like yeah you know but i bet you
privately he probably got an ass to one
from daddy's that's a big punishment and
not let him go to that event i mean if
you think about it what gets bigger for
a 16 year old kid
than being the face of this organization
there's no question about it there's
nothing
what do you do what do you do if i i
don't i don't see tico doing this
let's use dilly dilly cool guy playboy
seven years old
yeah you know he's he's in high school
he's a junior
he's a stud he's a running back he's the
uh
iranian bo jackson hanging out here and
uh maybe in florida maybe dallas
whatever
you know he's hanging out with chicks
he's drinking he's 17 it's homecoming
he's 17. he find out he's smoking weed
what do you tell dilly
dilly you know my approach will be a
different approach for me it's a lot of
preventative before we get there
it's not about when we get there if we
get there it's already too late i mean i
didn't do a good job having a
conversation with them
i'm going to tell them everything about
drugs remember i talked to these guys
about sex
about how babies are born at a very
young age and i talked to them about
their dangling and
their privates and all this stuff we're
still trying to recover yeah i know yeah
very early because for them to to be
aware of it so for me
you know there will be a couple
conversations and there's going to be
benefit packages
if you avoid certain things in life
meaning if if you avoid getting in
trouble with alcohol with drugs or
things like that
there's going to be levels one it's
going to be a card of your
choice then the next one is going to be
an investment into your business and the
next one's going to be a house to be
bought and that's the benefit of uh
you know being in a family where you can
make those kinds of uh benefit packages
so what's going to happen with our kids
i'm going to say listen you want to get
started i'm going to give you a big step
but here's the rules you can't do this
this this if you don't follow those
things
i'm good to go here's what i'm going to
give you and then you can do whatever
you want to do with it but uh
well two things on that yeah incentive
is the best way to do it but number two
it's the example you said if they see
you smoking weed they're it's probably
gonna happen if
you don't see that at home yeah we're
probably not smoking weed tonight that's
what i'm saying so yeah we're probably
not so
they never see it yeah so so you're
saying that you're going to set the tone
and then ramifications will be put in
place god forbid something happens
yeah the ben look listen my dad wasn't
there from 10 or 18 years old
i saw my dad once uh uh every other week
okay
so my dad and i have a great relation
but 10 18 i didn't see my dad and then
from 18 to 21 when i was in the army i
may have seen him five days
you know when i was in the army so about
two and a half years not seen that so
but but if my dad was there i was you
know
probably the biggest thing that my mom
did i got to give her credit for my mom
would say
you may do bad things that i will never
know about
but whatever bad you do god's going to
know 100 of things you do bad so forget
about me you can fool me you can lie to
me you cannot lie to him
he's going to know what you're doing
your mom said this my mom said this
she put the fear in god in me
at such an early age let me tell you it
is so effective
it is so effective to put that fear of
god i know your your
mom tried to get you to be a rabbi but
uh just wouldn't have
loved the conversation are you using
that same tactic with your kids
uh uh i i say it more from the
standpoint
of we are a special family god's always
protected us
uh i've been in the fire many times i
don't know why he's always been there
for me he's always been there for the
bed david family he's always come
through for us and i've done my best
to be a great soldier for him and we as
a family our family that's going to do
our part to be a great example during an
era that's needed that's the
conversation that we have
we speak about things like that it's not
more of you know
fear of god it's not my approach my
approach is don't get me wrong it's very
effective what she did 100 very
effective
but but it also kind of eliminates a
little bit of being loose so it made me
want to be
more pushing and challenging but it was
effective it definitely was effective
with what she did with that part